Pete Chatmon, Director/Podcaster/Author:
Sometimes when you're trying to make that
transition you're on two surfboards but you can't
ride them both at the same time it's impossible.
Film Courage: How many years was
it between showing at Sundance
and getting your first television directing job?
Pete: I went to Sundance in January of 2001.
I booked my first episode of
television in April of 2017.
Film Courage: Wow, that would be 16
and a quarter but you were active in film
and television you worked at NYU for a while
yeah I mean that whole time so to anyone everyone
watching and listening I never stopped being a
filmmaker and I think that's part of what
I try and touch on in the book like you're
you have to define yourself you have to claim
what you what you are and who you are and so
while I work the desk job at NYU I was assistant
production coordinator I was signing forms for
the students to go get film and rent equipment or
here's a voucher to go to kodak or whatever I was
this I was the signature toward other younger
folks dreams I answered a million questions at
the window because they would come to our window
and and get this information and I would give
unsolicited advice or it became sought
after people would kind of know that I had
a real world skill that I could
kind of impart and offer to them
I was I had my production company
during this time I had a podcast
I was making things I won a competition at Tribeca
for a heist screenplay that I co-wrote in 2008
I wrote a bunch of screenplays I
thought I might sell that I never did
and so all of that time I was still creating
trying to I had a target on feature filmmaking
because that was what I had gotten into this
game to do and over time this landscape was
changing it was the the the types of films that
I was kind of interested in making were becoming
obsolete because everything was coming from some
other intellectual property like a comic book or
an amusement park ride like pirates of the
Caribbean and like 20 million dollar films 10
million dollar films were kind of disappearing and
what I was noticing was a lot of the people that I
wanted that I was inspired by that made those
films were moving the tv because that's where
there was more there was a higher need there
they needed more they needed more content and
the filmmakers that were kind of sent to the
wayside by the new mandate and features were
going over to tv and saying well i'd love to tell
that kind of story and obviously all ushered in by
sopranos in the golden age and watching these
interesting characters find exploration episode
after episode season after season and so for yeah
I think from like 0-9 until 2017 I had a pretty
pretty dedicated focus on trying to get into tv
but it took some time before I was able to kind of
put it all together did you ever feel this sort
of common thing that someone took your chance
I see it in our comments and and I
can understand why people get angry
but did you ever feel that at times no I just
felt I never thought I never felt like someone
took my chance I was constantly trying to
find the cocktail that would work for me
to get the opportunity and what was
clear and I'm a person who went through
four director programs that the studios and
the networks were compelled to put together
because the hiring was so clearly angled in one
direction I just felt like well how do I get
access to the people who are making these
decisions I felt like that would be the big
that I knew that that was the biggest hurdle and
so that that hurdle was either making something
that people could see and doing that as often as
possible to give myself as many shots as possible
and then also discovering these programs where
you would get to learn how television was made
and be included in these cohorts and these units
that were selected to help bridge the gap between
93 of the directors being hired being white
males and 7 encompassed everyone else and so
those pipelines were helpful in kind of meeting
the folks learning how tv was made and then
hopefully shining enough to to get the
opportunities did anybody sit you down and say
pete I know you mean well but like why don't
you have you thought about going to law school
no right guy no nobody ever sat me down or tried
to send me in another direction I feel like
I was I never had I always had
people share maybe not the the the the strength of
belief in me but I feel like everybody in my world
believed in me because it was clear that
I was being very thoughtful about it
it wasn't like I didn't have like delusions of
grandeur of like what it was going to take from
me to get in the industry I was informed on how
it worked when I met a roadblock I tried to hop up
to 10 000 feet and look at it and then say well
what can I learn from this and how can I pivot
which is kind of the whole like through line of
the book it's like there's these you're gonna
you're gonna have your everybody's gonna have
their own journey and their own story but like
you're gonna find opportunities in
these challenges and and you have to
challenge yourself to respond with your
goal in mind and not with your emotion
and not with your you know anything else is this
your quote right here Pete yeah I said it may
I’ll take ownership I know maybe someone else
has said it somewhere in the world but yeah
if you ride the wave long enough the tide always
turns and what does that mean to me that just is
it means a lot of things I and it's funny I have
a lot of water metaphors like in the book I talked
about being a yacht in the road to getting your
first job you're like this luxury yacht that
doesn't have a slip to dock and you're trying to
build enough awareness in the marina for people to
offer you a slip so you can get off the boat
and walk on land and then another one that I
say often is sometimes when you're trying to
make that transition you're on two surfboards
but you can't ride them both at the same time it's
impossible and the reality of that is you're gonna
have to choose which one you're gonna get on you
can't ride them both you're gonna have to pick one
and step off of one in order to get to
where you're going and so this quote if you
why if you ride the wave long enough the
tide always turns is speaking to the idea of
for those of you who are trying and have
been trying to go after a singular goal
I can't remove being self-aware
and I can't remove being
being smart about the business and being open
to feedback but if you take those three things
and include that as kind of the back the
back end of this of this quote I think that
over a long enough timeline with those
three things powering you you'll find your
can it mean though that there
can also be a reversal of fortune
yeah I think I think exactly there can definitely
be a reversal you can it if you're seeing
hit after hit after hit or everybody loves
everything you do every time that you release
it or you do it it's probably going to come a
time where it's not going to be as well received
and then at that point I think then it just flips
to the other side and then you figure out how to
how to get out of that situation but what do they
say even a broken clock is right two times a day
like it's just I've found over my journey
that having things that remind me of
it's not destiny or it's not predetermined or it's
not like I'm not in some kind of I can't think of
the word I'm looking for I'm not in some kind of
like career purgatory what I mean like there's
ways to navigate the down times and most of it's
going to be about having a positive attitude.